The Joe Rogan experience.
Is that what you enjoyed the most about the stand up?
Yeah.
Uh,
no dramatic films I probably enjoy the most because I wanted to do that when I
was a kid,
I discovered that films existed.
I broke into Pinewood Studios,
one of our big studios when I was 15 broken.
Yeah.
Look like illegally.
Got It.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I was watching a film battle of Britain and at the end it says filmed on
location in Spain and anyway,
at Pinewood Studios,
I a heath bucks and I in the 70s and then remember we didn't have videos,
we couldn't freeze things over.
You'd have to scribble things down.
So I was scribbling down stuff off the end of films and I said,
I buy mysterious.
He was bucks.
Okay.
[inaudible] Ivy hate.
What does that,
but it was a bucks.
Okay.
Bucks a shot for Buckinghamshire.
That's to play either heath must be a town,
it's a weird name.
Town city,
village them to be a village or a town.
So I've got a map of the United Kingdom,
which has alphabetically every town and village and city.
They're going listed alphabetically.
And I went all the way down and I felt I are,
he's,
but okay.
That's where it is.
So I took a train from my,
the south coast of England,
up to London,
a tube train and underground train that to play school oxfords and a bus to
this,
this roundabout.
And I got off.
I said,
uh,
Pinewood Studios,
and they said,
it's about half a mile down that road.
So I marched down the road and I got to the big gabled entrance where all the
big stars would come in.
And I went up and I haven't got this bit worked out.
So I went up and I said,
um,
I'm going to,
I'm going to be in films,
can I come in please?
Uh,
it's what I've got to,
I've to make.
I gonna I want to be an actor.
Can I come in?
I want to just piss off kid.
No,
no.
It's just what I need.
Just told me to piss off.
And I thought,
no,
I've come miles.
This is a big,
so I thought there must be another way in.
So I went up and there was another entrance that was near it,
but it wasn't the main star enters.
It was just the,
they're kind of more,
Laurie enters the truck entrance,
the bringing stuff in,
and I saw people going into that.
There was a draw bridge,
a bit like where eagles dare the film either.
Anyway,
someone on the gate and some people was showing them passes and stuff and other
people just walking in.
So I thought,
okay,
you've got to have the confidence to walk in.
So I did the 16 1516 year old confidence and I just marched in and,
and suddenly I was through and I was in,
I was into Bible study.
So then in a spill we've broken the universal.
I broke into into thing.
He got a career going pretty immediately and I didn't get nothing.
Good.
Well,
you're 15 and I know,
here's what it was.
You expect,
what's going to happen?
What was your anticipation?
Anticipation was,
as I've said in a piece of standard that I,
cause I,
I had to walk at a certain speed.
If you're moving a certain speed,
I thought no one's going to stop you so you can't creep around looking.
Was this cause they said,
what are you doing here?
You know,
I just thought,
in fact it's kind of loose inside studios and no one really knows what everyone
else is doing,
so you can actually creep her out a bit.
But I move around at certain speed and I sort of March,
I was marching down streets and up arms and past studios and,
and I was hoping someone go,
hey you kid.
Yeah.
Uh,
wait,
you your marching around.
Yeah,
we're doing the film called the monitoring around kids.
A lead kid has just exploded.
Can you continue my,
yeah,
I come out.
You Ran,
can you say words?
Oxen.
String a few words together or gray leave.
I marched out of the same space.
We're done here.
I marched around for two hours and I marched that,
and I have since failed twice or three times in Pie with,
no,
I ain't gonna I want to do.
And whenever you tell them,
I go back and I'm actually filming that guy.
I broke in there and I just walk at very slow speeds down streets knowing that
anyone could stop me and I go,
I'm just filming around the code.
Just it's,
yeah.